saúl y sus amigos han utilizado una
aplicación de mensajería para platicar
entre ellos durante un año entero él
sospecha que en promedio cada uno envía
a los otros más de 100 mensajes por día
saúl toma una muestra aleatoria de 7
días de su bandeja de mensajería y
registran cuántos mensajes manda a cada
uno de sus amigos durante esos días los
datos de la muestra forman una
distribución fuertemente asimétrica a la
derecha con una media de 125 mensajes y
una desviación estándar de 44 mensajes
el quiere usar estos datos de la muestra
para realizar una prueba tema para la
media qué condiciones se deben cumplir
para realizar este tipo de pruebas de
significancia pensemos un poco en este
problema
saúl tiene una hipótesis nula tal vez la
haya leído en una revista o tal vez se
haya enterado de que el promedio de
mensajes envía
entre adolescentes es decir mensajes por
día entonces la hipótesis nolan es que
la cantidad promedio de mensajes
enviados por día a sus amigos es de 100
mensajes es decir no es distinto al
resto de los adolescentes ahora su
hipótesis alternativa será lo que él
sospecha y es justo lo que dicen por
aquí él sospecha que en promedio cada
uno envía a los otros más de 100
mensajes por día entonces la hipótesis
alternativa es que la cantidad promedio
de mensajes enviados por día a sus
amigos es de más de 100 mensajes así que
lo que hacen es tomar una muestra de la
población que va a ser esta de aquí y
son los 365 días del año porque dicen
que van usando esta aplicación durante
un año entero
ok y toma siete de esos días al azar por
lo tanto n es igual a 7 y con esta
muestra calcula sus estadísticos calcula
la media de la muestra que trata de
estimar la media verdadera de la
población y también calcula la
desviación estándar de la muestra ahora
recuerda lo que haces en una prueba de
significancia es pensar en cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener algo mayor o
igual a la media muestral suponiendo que
se cumplen
la hipótesis nula y si esa probabilidad
es menor que un cierto umbral
preestablecido entonces podremos
rechazar la hipótesis nula y sugerir la
hipótesis alternativa ahora para poder
sentirnos bien con esta prueba de
significancia y para poder ser capaces
de calcular este valor p con confianza
debemos cumplir ciertas condiciones la
primera es que nuestra muestra sea
verdaderamente aleatoria por lo tanto
esta será la condición de aleatoriedad y
lo hemos trabajado antes en los vídeos
sobre pruebas de significancia con
proporciones en este caso estamos
trabajando con medias la media de la
población la media de la muestra pero en
vídeos anteriores hablamos de la
proporción de la población y la
proporción de la muestra ahora podemos
decir que se cumple la condición de
aleatoriedad porque aquí en el problema
nos lo dicen
saúl toman una muestra aleatoria de 7
días no nos dicen cómo logra que sea una
muestra aleatoria pero podemos creerle
ahora la siguiente condición es la
condición de independencia y esta
condición nos pide que las observaciones
individuales sean aproximadamente
independientes
existen dos formas de asegurar esta
condición de independencia
la primera es tomar muestras con
reemplazo sin embargo no nos dicen que
se haya hecho así la otra forma de
asegurar esta condición de independencia
es asegurarnos de que el tamaño de la
muestra sea menor o igual que el 10% de
la población en este caso saúl tomó 7
días de 365 lo cual es en efecto menor
que el 10 por ciento ya que el 10% de
365 es 36.5 así que cumple esta
condición lo que nos asegura que se
cumple también la condición de
independencia y por último tenemos la
condición de normalidad
y esta condición nos dice que la
distribución muestral de las medias debe
ser aproximadamente normal ahora esto es
un poco diferente a lo que vimos con las
pruebas de significancia al trabajar con
proporciones existen algunas maneras de
sentirnos seguros de que la distribución
muestral de las medias es
aproximadamente normal
la primera es observando que la
distribución de la población originaria
sea normal ahora no nos dicen esto por
ninguna parte no nos dicen que existan
una distribución normal para el tiempo
que gastan en cada día así que no
podemos asegurar esta condición
otra forma sería asegurarnos de que el
tamaño de la muestra sea mayor o igual a
30 esto viene del teorema del límite
central y entonces nuestra distribución
muestra el sería aproximadamente normal
pero esto tampoco pasa podemos ver
claramente que el tamaño de la muestra
no es mayor o igual a 30 así que tampoco
se cumple esta condición ahora hay un
tercer caso y es asegurarnos de que la
distribución muestral de las medias sea
aproximadamente normal bien si nuestra
distribución fuera aproximadamente
normal entonces tendríamos una
distribución simétrica déjame bajar la
pantalla y no deberíamos de tener ningún
valor atípico sin valores atípicos
significativos ahora es éste el caso
bueno nos dicen que los datos de la
muestra forman una distribución
fuertemente asimétrica a la derecha con
una media de 125 mensajes y una
desviación estándar de 44 mensajes así
que es fuertemente asimétrica
la derecha y por lo tanto no cumplimos
ninguna de estas tres sub condiciones
para la condición de normalidad por lo
tanto podemos decir que no cumplimos la
condición de normalidad para nuestra
prueba de significancia nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo